after a very interesting talk from James
really really on the basis of Python
introducing us into many many very
interesting concepts we are now coming a
little bit more up from the machine room
and have more application oriented
perspective from Python those of you who
might have attended my tutorial on
Friday they know me already i will say a
couple of words about me in a minute why
my tutorial was more about interactive
analytics this talk is about derivatives
analytics which is a little bit more
involved in terms of what you need in
terms of mathematical finance and stuff
like that nevertheless all the examples
that ever present today are in an
interactive fashion but the underlying
machinery that we use is kind of a very
class object oriented approach should
have implemented I mean there's almost
for everybody or for anything there is a
library available in Python but not yet
one to do honestly derivative analytics
so what this talk is about I would start
with the prehistory of relevant finance
research for what I would be presenting
I will pre flee go into the differences
between analytical and numerical option
pricing then touch upon of course python
photo rivers analytics give an overview
of the library and also provide some
selected use cases from more simple one
to more complex one up until to the
collaboration of different models and
those of you have seen me already or met
with me might know that I'm managing
director Europe of continuum analytics I
found that position couple of years ago
where we started using Python
immediately so I do this applying Python
to the derivatives analytics arena
already since almost 10 years I am
lecturing mathematical finance also of
course using Python you might have seen
my book to relatives analytics with
Python and currently I'm writing the
book for Riley Python for finance has
also a little bit of derivatives
analytics but not too much my background
actually is in the roses analytics i
wrote the bottom a caching strategies
and the impact on volatility in
financial markets as always we're going
to talk you find the slides hosted on my
private website so if you want to go to
that he'll pitch calm you see the URL
there i tweeted also the link so if you
go to my twitter handle d ygh you will
find the link as well and then you can
follow it or see what's going on in here
a professor if option pricing research
there is a little bit of history so
actually as we know of today it started
all already in 1900 when a French guy
bajo de handed in his PhD thesis and was
researching a couple of years about
topic of option pricing actually at the
time when nobody has had the terms that
we have today like Eric metric Brownian
motion this is a term which was coined
pretty much later nevertheless at that
time the mathematical construct was of
high interest or Einstein Albert
Einstein wrote a famous paper at the
time in his Una's mirabilis 1905 and
provided first original theory for
promotion which is kind of the
cornerstone the major building block of
today's mathematical finance some reason
later rediscovered these approaches
first introduced by partial year but was
never able to really come up with a
closed form solution getting rid of any
ad hoc element this is actually due to a
place called Merton who partly
collaborated but published two papers in
1973 as most of you might know later two
of these guys were awarded the the Nobel
Prize for economics one was
unfortunately passed away already at
that time Merton then published for
example paper adding jump diffusion
which are quite popular and already in
1977 someone proposed to use Monte Carlo
simulation for the pricing of European
option I mean at the time when the when
these computers that you have heard so
many fantastic things about a at this
conference available but still the
method was introduced and later on they
the research team Carlos Rubenstein also
introduced a pretty efficient numerical
method also to value American option
it's not only to be normally of
surprising in terms of numerics but
their project was also able to value
efficiently American options for the
first time later on a couple of very
interesting things I want to highlight
the first valid point here Harrison
crepes pliska at the end of the 70s they
came up with the general risk neutral
valuation approach today so-called
fundamental theorem of asset pricing
where they used the machinery of
martingale theory to provide something
for a general market I mean when you
think of bricks kohls is one risk factor
there's one product this is a pretty
simple world we don't live in this
simple world we have a much more general
world where we have many many risk
factors recently when I her to talk of
analytics had at Morgan Stanley they
said they simulate 500 core risk factors
and twenty thousand others for the risk
simulator I mean this is the market that
we have we don't have a single one we
have many many risk factors and many
many products and the number that this
guy mentioned during the presentation
were three million positions to be
valued per day so we don't have a single
risk factor and a single product or a
single trade we have many many risk
factors and many many trades and this is
actually in theory introduced already at
the end of the 70s later on became a
couple of models that generalize in some
direction existing models like sarcastic
volatility was introduced by Heston in a
systematic fashion and he also
introduced freebase often pricing to the
financial world in that case we had
Bates who combined the jump diffusion
viscous elastic volatility and may be
worth highlighting is a long stuff
what's paper in terms of that it for the
first time provided an efficient
algorithm to value American options
which has been around almost 600 years
at the time with one the color
simulation so it took quite a while to
come up with an efficient algorithm to
value American option so heavily traded
I want the color simulation this was
kind of a breakthrough that allowed for
many many more analytically advances
later on actually what is the main
difference between radical option
pricing in America option pricing the
famous black schools formula as I said
has a single risk factor to traded
assets the one is a risky one as an
index or as a stock described here by
the geometric
Brownian motion and the other one is
kind of a riskless bond or a cash
account can think of it that way in this
simplified model they were able to come
up with this closed form solution really
say well I have a couple of input
factors I put them in here and then I
get a price for my option for the first
time Noah talk element was a model and
the closed form solution was a result
and it was even at that time pretty easy
to evaluate this function later on the
came out like Texas Instruments
calculators they had like implemented
this function so he only provided kind
of the input factors and the calculator
on your desk gave you the price for the
option so this was the state-of-the-art
at the time very efficiently you don't
need any kind of sophisticated or
high-performance machines to solve that
if you want to implement it in a
class-based object-oriented fashion and
Python it might look like that I mean a
couple of other ways to do that this is
self-contained fashion you have a couple
of input factors here attributes of the
class of the object and you have a
principal only one method which provides
the present value it is the calculation
of the formula in that sense once you
have in instantiate it such a class you
have your object which i call your call
i can call the method present value on
this object and i get back in a very
simple fashion my option price in this
case you should remember the number is
10 dot 45 so pretty simple pretty easy
five input factors one output the pewdie
and I mean the main reason for why
almost everybody is always looking for
analytical formulas is that it is pretty
efficient here you see I value 5,000
different options and on this macbook
air it takes roughly a little bit more
than a second to evaluate all these
options I mean this is quite efficient I
mean 5000 options on this notebook to be
valued I mean the bank will be happy if
this will be the case for every trade
that is in the books unfortunately it is
not because the majority of trades is
not as simple as
the stuff that we see here nor is the
world that you have to model that you
have to take into account as simple as
the model proposed and introduced by
flex codes merton at the time on the
other hand in Monte Carlo simulation
alternative what does this mean actually
this means that we work more with
approximations estimations based on
generally a large number of simulations
a large number of simulations in the
sense that I choose a capital I which
might be a hundred thousand might be a
million to simulate the path of my index
or stock level given a discretization
scheme of my differential equation so
this is numerical method and this is
pretty computationally demanding you see
we have lock functions we have squared
we have additions to do and if you want
to do this a million times or even
100,000 times this leads to quite a
different computational burden giving
actually the same problem in this case
but let us have a look how this could
look like in Python here again a pretty
simple class based implementation of the
same problem but now using what the
color simulation as an American method
see here there are two methods right now
I separated the past generation from the
from the evaluation effort here so here
this method generates all my pass given
a certain number maybe hundred thousand
to stick with this particular number and
the second methods called the first one
gets back to paths that are generated
and then calculates a net present value
and give this back so it looks pretty
similar we have an additional method but
in the end the same attributes I have to
give in a couple of numerical parameters
in this case M&I but I mean this is
quite the same thing as expected I mean
we are working in the same financial
world so the call and the instantiation
is almost same i instantiate my class
get back an object which i call now call
Carlo simulation
and when I call the method present value
I get back a present value this is not
exactly the same but as expected i mean
we're using an American method said that
before we have an approximation of the
value so this is not precise in a
certain sense but I mean it's pretty
close so I wrote here already quite good
what we can do of course is throw more
computing power to that we can add paths
to that you can say well 10,000 pass
might not be enough to 50,000 paths but
we see before it took like 50
milliseconds now we have already 300
milliseconds for a single valuation if
we now say well I can also control for
precision by hiring the number of time
steps the time crippe that they use to
approximate my differential equation for
the simulation I see well I come pretty
close to the 10.45 in this case but it
already takes three seconds just to
compare it 5,000 valuations in roughly a
second using monte carlo as an American
method for a single option three seconds
all on the same machine I mean these you
have to judge these values in relative
terms if you do it on a separate machine
may be using probably execution stuff
like that then the the absolute numbers
change but still here today this party
bus there is a huge difference in
performance but then you would say what
well how care i have this perfect method
work and value 5,000 options per second
why should I care what want the color I
mean on the color is a much much more
flexible method but a little bit more
about this this chapter called some
general considerations there are
potential problems with analytical
formula I mean as I said with the with
the texas instruments calculator even
yeah everybody not working in in the
finance industry can calculate by a
display box approach option value at me
without knowing anything but on the
other hand if you're an expert and you
understand it fully this is still the
kay is that they're limited only
specific use cases this also know
consists
Valley aggregation in the sense that you
if you value different options with
different models different parameters
what is the point in adding these up
when there are for example correlations
in existence and you have to model
different underlines no consistent risk
a kekkaishi I mean risk echo get value
address credit barriers and stuff like
that a netting operation is very
important to have the full distribution
which is not provided here we only have
a point estimate we only work with the
expectation parameter with nothing else
and the last point emphasizes again no
incorporation of any kind of correlation
in that case but of course we have
advantages so I mean that's a beauty of
the analytical approach that's easy to
understand and apply a sea formula I put
something in I get something back in
general AF high speeds for the numerical
evaluations low technical requirements
you can do this on even the smallest
machine or raspberry pi your name it has
actually no problem at all and it's also
easy to test and implement a leech
drawbacks of alternative American
methods such as simulation I mean they
are compute-intensive we have seen that
100,000 50,000 completed a pass with 500
times that this is already computational
burden of course there is a memory a
demand which arises out of this we have
accuracy issues which we have to control
for conceptual problems for example
American exercise is much more involved
than European exercise in this case and
we also have implementation issues it's
a little bit harder typically too new to
implement numerical methods compared to
just kind of closed formula testing and
maintenance like test coverage for
example are also typically more complex
but on the other hand and now we come to
the point why the whole world uses it
right now it is highly flexible and
powerful it can use almost any model
model with the numerical method any
derivative any portfolio compared to the
hex codes world you have only this one
single model for the underlying and you
can apply it only to put a call option I
mean this is very limited given the
millions of different products and and
trades we have in the world there's a
very limited scope with a full
distribution of you when you think of
risk we have
all the frequency distributions for
everything you can think of if
consistent value aggregation we use
these methods consistently we have
consistent risk measures because we have
full distribution not only first order
approximations in which are used in some
cases also consists in estimation of
letting effects path wise namely it's
very granular how you can implement
these techniques consistent
incorporation also of time for Ryan
correlations maybe and last but not
least full graphical analysis no black
boxes or even small corners of the
algorithm here just to illustrate it
this is the data I have generated by the
Monte Carlo simulation beforehand you
can inspect almost anybody this is one
of the most simple examples you can
generate this is the the frequency
distribution the full distribution of
the simulated values at the end of our
time period that we consider so you have
a look or you can have a look into every
single data point no black boxes nothing
behind the scenes in this case I mean
you have to judge all the things that
you see today against against the
background of technology advances i mean
when i wrote my PhD thesis fortunately
at the time i wrote a theoretical one so
i didn't need a computer apart from
writing it up and publishing it i had
only a couple of america examples but if
it would have liked to implement for
example montecarlo evaluation it would
have been much much more hard to do than
today at that time you had single core
computers only low-level programming
languages available like c and for tron
so it would have been a high burden to
reach some kind of high performance or
acceptable performance it would have
cost me much much more than i would have
had probably at the time as a PhD
student but today it's even for ya let's
say not well equipped PhD students not
very rich ones may be coming from a good
background it's pretty simple to rent
like one machine after the other on
cluster structures or whatever you have
many cause large memories powerful GPU
even on your local machines you have
high level programming language which
allows scientists today to implement
even the most complex algorithms quite
efficiently and you have low and I think
Mariah bill might also be a very
important factor costs for even large
machines so you can scale you can buy a
computing power for one day as a
researcher and say well I did all my
calculations fine now I'm done I mean
times have changed and even more so for
banks who have large budgets and
business cases to support such
infrastructures or exchanges to this end
of course as well the external it aches
what what is it was it what is about we
come now to the core it's based on
general risk neutral variation what is
typically called in a practical work
global valuation which means that you
model your risk factors only ones non
redundantly and then on top of that on
the simulated world you value your
single trades or products when the
cardia simulation is the only numerical
method which is able to cope with such a
world in terms of valuation in creeks
for a base formula which are pretty
really fast for calibration purposes you
can have arbitrary models it's pretty
flexible single and mighty risk
derivatives European and American
exercise it's completely implemented DD
library and Python and hardware isn't
that sends not the limiting factor it
can easily scale it cope evaluation at
its core means actually non-redundant
modeling you have more your model risk
factors only once you have consistent
simulation for example in terms of the
given correlations that you assume you
have in the end as a result consistent
value and risk aggregation which allows
you really to have a clear and
consistent economically financially
consistent view on your positions and
you can have you can zoom in on single
positions but you have also a consistent
net view on the portfolio on the whole
portfolio on the trading book python
specifics I have only three points here
it's not like today they use some magic
things here of course heavy use of
classes and object orientation numpy
ndarray class mainly also ponders they
differ ends and stuff like that for
numerical data and Python dictionary are
heavily used for all major data so the
the accessing time and efficiency of
Python dictionary
is I think one of the major strengths
that you can apply here in this case
some simple example it's a library so
from the exfoliation that import
everything start by discounting so for
example have it's the most simple class
it's a constant rate class i instantiate
a discount object if you like a short
rate object with five percent
discounting rate i have a timeless here
in this example i started the middle of
this year go to the end of the year this
could be any time list I just generated
it using Ponder's for convenience I
provide this timeless to get back the
discount factors maybe the maybe the
naming might be a little bit confusing
so I wrote here a remark and that is
it's the price of unit zero coupon bond
values so the classical way of
discounting in derivatives analytics
which means at the end of the horizon
the price of the unit zero coupon bond
is one and you have the net present
value of this pond today and using the
factor of dot 97 allows you to discount
from the last day to this state and the
discount factors in between have to be
calculated given the current values at
this particular date you can also
provide apart from PI daytime objects
you can provide which is usually done in
theory also year fraction so they say
half a year from now for example which
would be reflected by dot 504 in this
case so you can go two ways but I try to
do it as pathetic as possible so using
pi datum objects and all the typical
things that you would expect from the
pythonic derivatives library but this
might be more geared toward researchers
or academics a market environment of
course we are not like in a theoretical
world and ivory tower there is a market
around us so for example here I start
and senshi ating a class an object for a
jump diffusion j d stands for jump
diffusion I just give it a name and the
pricing date and you see here this is
indeed kind of a beast out of my library
and it's called market environments or a
very specific Beast which I can now fill
with
relevant values like the initial value
of something volatility lambda you don't
need to understand all the single
details we will see the results later on
but again I provide everything similar
to the Plex colts example before that I
need to value derivatives based on my
market based on my environment you see I
add a couple of constants these are
single values could be a string for
example for the currency or I provide
other objects curves more complex
animals that live in this world in this
case it is the discount curve are that I
have instantiate it before now we come
to the model I mean the whole thing is
geared towards pricing derivatives and
doing analytics on that so we have to
have our underlying our risk factor in
this case we only have one risk factor
which is called JD for jump diffusion
you see this is a class out of the out
of the library when this class has
attached a couple of methods in this
case for example get instrument values
and the instrument various are like the
results of the simulation procedure that
we have seen before for the Monte Carlo
case of blake's colds and I just print
or till the last values these are the
various will c minus one for the last
column in my array and you're getting
the simulation results the single ones
for the last date for the majority to
value the option at hand so you can of
course plot everything and you see the
typical behavior of a jump diffusion I
assumed a large jump size that it can
detect the jumps quite easily see this
will be more likely to bigger geometric
Brownian motion this is like moving with
a certain bullet ility and was drift but
here you see two jumps occurring with a
certain probability over a year or in
this case over half a year and also with
a certain jumped size which is
distributed lock normally so there are
variations in the chomp size this would
maybe reflect some crises or bad news
for a stock for example disappointing in
terms of earnings expectations now the
option for the option we need as well a
market environment
this one is pretty easy the only thing
that I provide here is the currency we
have already assumed the majority of
parameters that we need and you see here
i instantiate the evaluation class for a
call that i want to value i give it a
name I give the market environment I
provide the underlying risk factor for
the single risk variation class and I
provide in pythonic fashion this doesn't
have to be but just to illustrate how it
works internally I provide in Python
accession the payoff of the option which
is a standard pay off for a call option
which means the maximum of the value of
my underlying at maturity minus the
strike price in this case is 100 and 0
so it's a typical payer for a European
option pretty simple this is actually
the same that you could value with plex
Colts model but the naplex codes model
we couldn't include the jump component
this was done later bye-bye Merton
though this reflects the set up of more
1976 if now a couple of methods that I
can call the present value of course
this is maybe the most important thing
but for trading and risk management
purposes you might be even more
interested in the Delta or the Vega
which is the first derivative with
regard he in this case in numerical
derivatives with regard to change a
small change in marginal change in the
underlying or a small change in the
volatility of my risk factor we can do a
little bit more analytics people like to
have it visually so we go over a couple
of prices a couple of starting values if
you like for our underlying what we see
here we see different present values of
course for a call the call as much in
the money we have a high value you see
the typical data structure coming from
close to zero approaching one at the
single time and here we see the spiking
bigger around the strike price so you
can do similar things that I used to do
with the closed formula like duplex
colds one there a couple of others but
it's the most popular one you can
here in quite a similar fashion but the
underlying implementation is completely
numerically based in the sense that we
only use Monte Carlo simulation for all
the things that you see here now a
little bit of a more complex structure
what we've seen so far is pretty easily
implemented you can even write it up
when you're pretty on your bit
experience you can open your ipython
notebook and write your difference
equation and simulated and come up with
a price but you won't have something
maybe that is a little bit more general
so we do something with multiple
correlated risk factors and also with
multiple derivatives so that we come to
at least a more realistic case you could
think of kind of yeah larger hype reach
trade that the bank wants to implement
with a couple of derivatives or a hedge
fund which is a bit more complex this
doesn't resemble a kind of a training
book of a bank but it's more like a
complex trait that you could dedicate
encounter in a hedge fund or an
investment bank so once again this is
pretty similar we have our short red
object there are others available but I
stick with them with a simple one that
we have here we instantiate three
different underlyings now I will skip
pretty quickly through these we have a
geometric Brownian motion in this case
we have a jump diffusion that we have
seen before and we also have something
with stochastic volatility here in this
case they will need a little bit more we
need Volvo a cop r theta roll on the
sheer low lumber is not needed because
we don't model the jump diffusion we
only use the stochastic volatility part
so we have three different risk factors
which are based on three different
popularly used models in finance all the
things that are common to the market I
collect in a valuation environment and
at the valuation environment to every
single market environment of my
underlyings so this is pretty simple
like it's kind of an inheritance it's
got to say once i have defined the major
meta data points i can provide them to
every
your market environment that I've
written up in this case it's kind of the
last step to finish the modeling of the
market I say well what is given my
market what are the underlying this is a
dictionary as you can see and I provide
the correlations as a list of a list so
i assume two correlations one between
the game image from kelowna motion jump
diffusion which is positive and one
between the jump diffusion and a
stochastic volatility which is highly
negative in this case now that your
relatives I have a simple one American
put option I have to provide a couple of
information once again this put option
is based on my geometric Brownian motion
here in this case I can without thinking
of portfolio or adding all the things up
I just can simply value this single this
single option this in this case an
American option by providing again
market environment specifying the
underlying and providing the payoff and
I get back here in this case the net
present value of my option which is in
this case 4.49 now it gets a little bit
more involved we have the European
maximum call on two assets now we will
have two underlyings to risk factors
once again I need of course a market
environment nothing exists on it own I
have a market that have to take into
account here in this case you see of
course the payoff of this call actually
will include two different underlying
values it is the maximum of the two
relevant risk factors but apart from
that is actually the same in this case
to adjust value this single option i
define kind of a subset of a market i
say well these are the two relevant
assets the correlations are the one that
I have to find before I have fear a
variation object which is not cold or
instantiated from the class valuation
montecarlo multi European becomes larger
because it becomes more complex and in
the end it all works saying once I have
this beast I can just call the present
value method I and get
back in the same fashion as I was used
to for example when using flex colds my
value for this more complex object now I
of course have to delta's if i want to
calculate them one with regard to the
first risk factor one with regard to the
other risk factor so the word as i said
becomes more and more complex not only
one data to and of course i have also to
vega components here what I now do here
is a let's say 3d visualization of all
the stuff that I've done the code is not
that relevant but what we see here when
we plot the present value as you can see
the present value independence of the
two risk factors of my to underlying
object what you can also do is to
visualize the creeks in 3d you see the
Delta here in this case with regard to
the geometric Brownian motion on the
other hand the Delta the derivative with
respect to the initial value of the jump
diffusion on the other axis so you can
do like a more complex analytics with
the derivatives but in the same fashion
once again as you might be used to using
analytical formula this is the Delta now
for the jump diffusion looks a little
bit different but you have just to
change the orientation then it might be
give you this yeah a similar impression
you might notice this is more like you
see from the one side into it and here
you see from the complete the other side
on the thing but nevertheless they can
do analytics once again in a very
compact fashion providing all the
different risk factors that you need to
hatch and to manage your positions last
but not least the same thing for Vega
here we have to Vega with respect to the
geometric Brownian motion sensor spike
around the around the strike over here
which behaves a little bit differently
in this case in the jump diffusion
direction and once again we see this
thing but now the video with respect to
the jump diffusion with a different
orientation you know have tea despite of
that over there again at roughly thirty
four which is to strike in this case now
to make it a little bit more complex
even a minimum put onto assets but now
with the American exercise now it gets
involved if multiple risk factors and we
have American exercise this is already
kind of a trick in America thing but the
whole thing details are not that
important pay of changes but the whole
thing is mainly the same you can value
it understand the loan fashion similarly
to the most simple one as before we have
you Vegas your deltas and everything are
the same once you have this object it
behaves like the most simple one that
you can conceive so all is quite similar
but now we are coming to the more
interesting part putting all the things
together doing one market one trading
book out of it to this end we define
three derivatives positions another
class which is called derivative there
are a couple of differentiations right
now the most important one is of course
that you might have different numbers of
the single object in it here in this
case to make it simple i have two of the
first 13 of the second one and five of
the last one that we've seen to make a
difference between the single positions
and you can add this to a portfolio you
say right now well these are my
positions now make a portfolio class out
of that put all the things in that my
positions my evaluation environment all
the underlyings that i have end the
correlations this defines know my market
and in the end with the positions also
my portfolio nobody can do i can hand in
a very simple fashion by a single method
call you get a statistics this is kind
of customizable you can add in here
whatever you like this is just formatted
print out using pandas you get
information about all the things that
you have no idea you have this position
this is the name the quantity the value
of a single thing here's the position
very
which means x the number of products you
have in there 22 Delta's and the to
Vegas if there are two but what is
noteworthy in this environment you have
to remember maybe the 17 and 23 roughly
40 together we would see the effect of
changing the collation actually but
again you have portfolio this is already
three risk factors too rather complex
products one mainly standard product but
you can easily add up and you have a
consistent risk and value aggregation in
this case in this case where we have
seen in statistics before we have a high
correlation high positive correlation
between geometric Brownian motion at the
jump no jump of course here in the blue
line and you see their move pretty
closely a pretty similar behavior if we
now change the correlation between
geometric Brownian motion in the jump
diffuse de- dot seven we see also change
in the values and I mean this is what
everybody's interested in if you model
the market right what are the effects
not only the net effect was also single
effects given my portfolio before we had
17 and 23 it's roughly 40 it was roughly
40 now we see correlation changes the
net value of my portfolio doesn't change
but we see a change in a single value is
because we have correlation options
minimum and maximum options of multiple
assets are nothing more nothing less
than correlation options and you see
here with this approach with the library
can easily take into account every
single element and of course as I said
before you can also inspect what is
happening this is exactly the same path
that I've shown before see this movement
but now we have this highly negative
correlation and you see exactly how the
market is no model and how it evolved so
miracle ii in this particular case here
so it's very very granular you have a
rather general approach called global
valuation just to give an idea i mean
i've been working in kind of a
laboratory environment i mean i assumed
a couple of parameters like an initial
value of volatility and stuff like that
this is rather academic but of course
you want to price your options in a
market-based fashion which means to
select what the market is giving you and
this is usually then an exercise of
calibrating the model those of you have
attended my tutorial on Friday might
remember that I'm or have done a little
bit of work with volatility derivatives
I just want to show right now as the
last example how you can calibrate a
model that is provided by the library to
real market data and to replicate option
prices only a couple of imports I need
of course data to cali prey to this is
data from the last training date of 2012
a little bit of instantiation I need to
provide a couple of data to this model
it's a more complex one I have a have
specific classes for the calibration
here in this case is called as a JD a
calibration for square with jump
diffusion calibration and the first
thing I do here in this case is do a
term structure collaboration which means
I take all the futures prices and first
calibrate my futures curve the model
doesn't provide too many degrees of
freedom to resemble the like of
sophisticated structures but you see
this is kind of like a regression
approach through this and the
differences are taken into account later
on when I value the single options so
it's the first step global optimization
and now have a set of parameters six to
be specific which I can use to calibrate
the model to the market and here see a
global calibration procedure it's not
too long takes a couple of seconds and I
have a first result here we have the
mean squared error of all my 39 option
prices in this case but global
collaboration might not suffice I can go
one step further but first the results
here here you see what calibration means
we have the market data which are the
blue lines and we have the red dots
which are my model prices so what I want
in a perfect model world I want to
perfectly replicate my market by my
model various I mean then I have the
perfect model we would have this for
every market I could make you
moans of money here you see we have
still quite huge differences given our
market price so we have to optimize the
collaboration itself by local
optimization and here you see I do 100
runs which is not too much but it takes
quite a while here in this case almost
two minutes but there's no probable is a
shins all done here on my machine based
on Monte Carlo simulation I must confess
so to say this is numerical
collaboration approach if implemented
this also in parallel and it scales
quite linearly with the number of cores
involved so there shouldn't be a
bottleneck if you have more complex
problems but let's see how good we can
become and you see here it's coming much
much better we are much closer here on
the prices this is the last maturity
date of the restocks options in this
case it was august 2013 this is the
shortest majority which was january 2013
but you see the collaboration fit is
much much better than we have before so
the library in essence provides
everything from the modeling of the most
simple objects that you might face in
the market up until calibration I would
skip this is a little bit of background
so if you're working on this since a
couple of years we've also written up
derivatives analytics library which we
provide why our web-based delivery
approach you find it under derivatives
analytics com they can register for
example for a free trial to have a
summary about the external it takes its
pythonic it's completely based empandas
numpy there's no specifics i mean if
they used to python you might be up to
speed pretty quickly it's pretty
flexible you've seen you can model many
many things multireal single risks
complex structures you can calibrate
it's consistent in a sense that every
single data point is aggregated is
netted in a consistent fashion is easily
enhanced able I mean it's
object-oriented you can add new models
on the fly if you like new features can
be added on the fly it's a performance
performance here in this case means for
standard Python I've used all the
techniques
are available there's no polarization or
whatsoever included right now but this
is easily edited as well it's pretty
easy to integrate it for example if you
think of solutions such as data a nitro
which allows you to script Excel you can
easily implement like an Excel
spreadsheet as a front-end and use the
library to model your derivatives and to
value them and to do portfolio analytics
or whatever you might want to do and
using XO in that sense as a graphic
upfront and for the library and it's
open I mean to the use of a market
environment the project can connect with
any database thomson reuters bloomberg
you name it any database can be
integrated you need only simple wrappers
where you get your data out of your data
providers database and put it in to the
valuation procedure the last thing i
will skip but is one of my standard
slides why we should use python I mean
the library is not that large it was
able for me to write it up personally as
a pet side project I mean this says a
lot I mean in banks are like hundreds or
even thousands sometimes working on on
similar stuff so python is I think the
right language the light technology
environmental platform to accomplish
these analytics goals in a sense thanks
it depends on the only thing the only
type of models that have been shown is a
parametric model so I've used for
example of stochastic volatility model
which you could calibrate by itself for
example through world surface in the
last step where you've seen the
calibration that I used if you like to
the world surface to calibrate the model
and tell you the options innocent with
the Monte Carlo structured products
might want to use
volatility mean your simulations a bit
more oh I I don't have shown any local
vol example today only parametric models
in the sense that we working with like
the economic parameters and not a
numerically fitted to the market but
it's DT procedure and the approach would
be exact the same only the underlying
mechanics with the steam from the GPA
and then I haven't shown the values for
the graphics that we've seen was for the
geometric Brownian motion and the jump
diffusion they of course have the single
ball parameter yeah yeah but as I said
the graphics were not with regard to the
stochastic volatility in the lab you're
right the last example included the last
example where I haven't shown the
graphics this is included in that sense
I have standardized the input parameter
to shock the original sarcastic
differential equation a difference
equation even though if I you can take
the volvo parameter or the initial
volatility and what I do is to shock the
initial volatility for that or the
initial variance if you like so this is
what i shock in this case if you would
like hold the stochastic volatility part
constant you would end up with the
brakes colts model in a sense and this
is what i shock in this case